[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück bei uns
halten sie sich fest heute ist der
teuerste tag der deutschen des jahres
wieso erst mal alles nach dem schlafen
land oder er gestern verabschiedet
parlamenten gesetzentwurf zur senkung
der energie steuer das tanken soll
endlich billiger werden der liter benzin
wird damit um 30 cent pro liter weniger
besteuert einschließlich der
mehrwertsteuer sogar um 35 cent bei
diesel sind es 14 cent pro liter mit
mehrwertsteuer dann sogar 17 cent
niedriger steuern die gelten im juni
juli und august ja doch was so
beschwingt daher kommt das kostet und
zwar ordentlich die maßnahme kostet den
bund vor und voraussichtlich etwa drei
milliarden euro an steuern er und dieses
gesetz passierte den bundestag ohne
gegenstimmen ralf schuler ist für uns
bei der bundespressekonferenz hier in
berlin die gerade stattfindet ja
entlastungen ja die gibt es für die
bürger da freuen wir uns natürlich alle
aber reif sagt man im großen und ganzen
ist das doch eigentlich eine luftnummer
oder weil das sorgt ja für schon enorme
probleme
das ist wie bei vielen
guten dingen die der staat uns zu können
scheint am ende bezahlen wir sie selbst
wenn der staat hat gar kein anderes geld
als unseres nämlich das steuergeld und
aus diesem topf gibt er uns jetzt
einiges zurück um zb den preisanstieg
bei energieträgern bei benzin und bei
transportdienstleistungen ein bisschen
zu dämpfen da kriegen wir also etwas von
dem zurück was wir vorher schon gezahlt
haben es ist heute nacht die längste
nacht im parlament die im jedes jahr
stattfindet vonstatten gegangen die
sogenannte bereinigungssitzung da
treffen sich die haushaltsexperten
klingt nicht sehr erotisch das sind aber
sehr mächtige menschen die haben die
gesamte haushaltsplanung die sitzen auf
dem geld des bundes und in dieser
bereinigungssitzung werden die letzten
millionen hin und hergeschoben ich
wollte noch für parkhäuser von fahrrad
parkhäuser an bahnhöfen zum beispiel
wollten die grünen gerne haben da haben
sie noch mal 30 millionen dafür bekommen
die
künstlersozialkasse hat nochmal 60
millionen bekommen das war ein anliegen
auch der fdp und so wird dann so im ganz
kleinen millionenbereich hin und her
geschoben und es werden die letzten
ecken festgezurrt unter anderem übrigens
auch die regelung für das büro von
altkanzler gerhard schröder das waren
die haushälter die sich darauf geeinigt
haben dass in dieser sitzung fest
zuzügen es wird gestrichen weil das
nicht benutzt und im interessant an der
an diesem vorgang ist im übrigen das ist
auch die anderen altkanzler büros
betrifft und die der bundespräsidentin
denn wenn die nichts mehr machen und
nichts mehr zu tun haben oder sagen ich
ziehe lieber nach florida dann werden
künftig die wiese büros und die stellen
dafür gestrichen nicht das ruhegehalt
das behalten sie auch nicht der
personenschutz aber die büros und die
stellen könnten gestrichen werden es
wird also vom alten statusdenken er war
einmal kanzler deshalb bis zum
lebensende seinen status und sein büro
wird um gewechselt zum
anspruchsdenken zum aufgabenerfüllung
denken wenn keine aufgaben mehr da sind
gibt es auch kein büro das ist ein ganz
schöner paradigmenwechsel nicht so
besonders
gelungen ist der stellen auf vox der
bund gönnt sich mal wieder netto etwa
6000 neue stellen auch ein altes
leidiges ritual immer wenn neue
regierungen kommen finden sie ganz neue
aufgaben die gelöst werden müssen und
dafür müssen selbstverständlich auch
neue stellen geschaffen werden wir sind
am ende über 8000 aber auch ein paar
stellen wegfallen kommt man bei 6 raus
ob das wirklich alles nötig ist das wird
dann der
steuerzahlerbund analysieren und es gibt
eine ganz kleine sparbemühungen 0,6
prozent aller stellen sollen am ende der
legislaturperiode wieder eingespart sein
ob das kommt da kann man große
fragezeichen haben und auch 140
milliarden euro neue schulden soll es ja
geben im haushalt jetzt für dieses jahr
ralf was kann das bedeuten
ja es gibt eine ganze reihe aufgaben die
nicht finanzierbar sind aus den
steuereinnahmen obwohl der bund zu viel
einnimmt wie noch nie und dafür werden
halt neue schulden aufgenommen das sind
zum beispiel steuererleichterungen jetzt
eben dieses dieses pulver paket für
mobilität und energie aber sind eben
auch sehr große posten liegengeblieben
aus der korona zeit kurzarbeitergeld und
andere
zahlungen die man geleistet hat um
einfach die volkswirtschaft am laufen zu
halten die müssen jetzt bezahlt werden
und deshalb
hat der finanzminister der eigentlich
dachte mit 100 milliarden schulden
auskommen zu können 139 milliarden neue
schulden aufnehmen müssen interessant
daran ist dass auch fünf milliarden
rückstellungen getroffen worden sind für
zu erwartende
zinsdienste das heißt die
bundesregierung geht davon aus dass die
zinsen wieder steigen werden und das
dann auch die kredite des bundes sehr
viel teurer werden also das ist eine
interessante geschichte durch die
nullzinspolitik der europäischen
zentralbank war das mit geld borgen
bislang eigentlich so sensationell
günstig dass man eigentlich gar nicht
als politiker mehr wusste warum man
nicht schulden machen sollte langsam
ziehen die zinsen wieder an und dann
wird es eben auch teurer 5 milliarden
hier sind geld was man auch für andere
sinnvolle dinge hätte ausgeben können
besten dank ralf schoula für diese
einordnungen ja man fragt sich ob auch
diese meldung hier dann eigentlich eine
gute ist ab juni wird bahnfahren richtig
günstig gestern abend da machte der
bundestag den weg für das 9 euro ticket
frei 25 milliarden euro gibt der bund
den ländern damit sie den spaß im öpnv
und regionalverkehr bezahlen können mit
dem ticket kann dann jeder von juni bis
august für neun euro pro monat den
gesamten deutschen nahverkehr nutzen
heute heute gibt es den showdown um neun
euro ticket im bundesrat
und wer uns im studio ist jetzt reiner
holznagel präsident vom bund der
steuerzahler ganz herzlich willkommen
schön dass sie bei uns sind hallo es
soll eine menge beschlossen werden dass
neun euro ticket auch an der tankstelle
soll es günstiger werden sind das gute
lösungen oder ist das etwas was uns
eventuell dann wieder von hinten ein
holt es ist erstmal großes flickwerk und
wir hoffen dass das auch wirklich bei
den bürgerinnen und bürgern ankommt ob
die benzinpreise wirklich fallen das
liegt auch ein stück weit an den
mineralölkonzernen und wir hoffen dass
die gesunkenen preise denn auch
weitergegeben werden aber sicher ist das
nicht 30 cent sollen besteuert werden
reicht das denn aus oder muss noch mehr
kommen wir hätten strukturell da
rangehen müssen die mineralölsteuer
abzusenken ist richtig aber langfristig
und nach drei monaten haben wir dann
wieder die hohen preise insofern muss
die politik aus meiner sicht nicht nur
um einen kurzfristigen zeitraum handeln
sondern auch langfristig die bürger
bleiben stark belastet dadurch und durch
diese absenkung entsteht ja auch andere
druck beispielsweise engpässe bei der
treibstoffversorgung das wird noch mal
interessant ob es wirklich alles rund
läuft der bundeshaushalt für dieses jahr
der steht fest und fast 140 milliarden
neue schulden sollen aufgenommen werden
was stört sie persönlich im
bundeshaushalt 2022 am meisten ja die
haben ja bis in die nacht getagt und was
rausgekommen ist es sind noch mehr
ausgaben also es wird nicht wieder
gespart insofern haben wir einen den
höchsten bundeshaushalt fast 500
milliarden mit 140 milliarden euro
neuverschuldung das ist richtig viel
geld und diese schulden müssen
irgendwann ja auch mal zurückgezahlt
werden aber was überhaupt nicht sehen
kann ist dass gespart wird das einzige
womit sie sich rüsten ist dass schröder
kein büro mehr hat aber das rettet uns
nicht wirklich
wo wird es denn für uns besonders teuer
die energiepreise bleiben hoch und da
wird es wahrscheinlich auch keine
entwarnung geben deswegen hat man aus
meiner sicht auch hier mal über die
mehrwertsteuer nachdenken müssen nicht
nur temporär sondern strukturell der
strompreis muss sinken auch als
alternative zu fossilen energieträgern
aber das wird so bleiben und wenn die
energie hoch bepreist wird werden auch
lebensmittel weiterhin teuer bleiben
also ich sehe nicht ein ende der
inflation deswegen brauchen wir
eigentlich eine steuerpolitische andere
antwort und das könnte der staat ja
jetzt bringen ganz konkret sind die
pakete die jetzt geschnürt werden eine
schulnote vielleicht welche schule
können sie diesen paketen geben die
werden wir bürgerinnen und bürger
wirklich entlastet also ich habe bis
jetzt noch keinen gefunden der sich
wirklich darüber freut alle merkel und
alle fans komisch alles ist sehr
bürokratisch insofern durchgefallen und
das was man hätte machen müssen hat man
nicht gemacht nämlich die kalte
progression komplett abschalten das
hätte allen geholfen unter anderem auch
den rentnern und wir hätten nicht diese
flickschusterei und vor allen dingen
hätten wenn ich diesen enormen
bürokratischen aufwand und da gibt es ja
auch immer mehr stellen beim bund jetzt
wieder neu geschaffen 6000 stellen was
haben wir denn überhaupt davon ja das
fragen wir uns auch der bundestag wächst
nicht nur viele abgeordnete sondern auch
neue stellen überall wird draufgesattelt
und das ist eines unserer großen
kritikpunkte das nicht wirklich gespart
wird überall wird draufgesattelt überall
kommt mehr dazu aber uns bürgern sagt
man wohlstandsverlust wir müssen den
gürtel enger schnallen ich fände es gut
wenn die bundesregierung und auch der
bundestag anfang und die verkleinerung
des bundestages werde man eine schöne
maßnahmen könnte man einen guten
beispiel vorangehen für welche
bürgerinnen und bürger glauben sie was
denn besonders schmerzhaft schauen wir
auf die rentner schauen wir auf die
familien schauen wir auf pendler es
glauben sie erwähnt sie haben die
gruppen schon genannt auch gerade die
pendler die ihn nicht auf den öpnv
umsteigen können ich finde die debatte
manchmal ein bisschen unterirdisch wir
haben große landstriche in deutschland
das funktioniert der öpnv nicht
beziehungsweise er gibt ihnen es gibt
denen dann gar nicht und die menschen
sind aufs auto angewiesen insofern ist
die debatte manchmal ohne demuth aber
auch rentner und geringverdiener sind
hier wirklich stark gebeutelt deswegen
hätte man da was machen müssen die kalte
progression wenn man sie wirklich
komplett abbauen würde das würde allen
helfen eine familie mit 36.000 euro
brutto die würde 250 euro im jahr sparen
das ist eine steuerersparnis von 20
prozent hat man aber nicht gemacht wenn
man jetzt bis zu sagen würde würde man
sagen hätte hätte fahrradkette ist aber
nichts passiert dafür sind wir aber auch
da also noch mal ganz kurz auf den punkt
verpasst muss jetzt passieren wir müssen
die steuern senken und das strukturell
und planbar die kalte progression muss
abgestellt werden der
einkommensteuertarif muss verändert
werden beispielsweise die debatte um den
mindestlohn ist auch ein bisschen schräg
wenn er kommt zahlen die wesentlich mehr
steuern also wir müssen eine bessere
steuerpolitik machen sagt reiner
holznagel vielen herzlichen dank für
ihren besuch hier im studio franken